Joining me today is an author,
the Co founder and president of
environmental progress.org
and a candidate to be the next governor
of the great state of California.
Mike shellenberger.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Just having me.
David.
I am very jealous of your beard.
Even the amount of gray here.
I just added that before I do the
reverse.
What do they do?
It's just for men usually takes the gray
out.
Exactly.
You do the training of the baby boomer
votes.
Added some gray in.
Yeah.
I'm very excited to talk to you because
I think this is going to be a good
political discussion,
but also we'll get to some environmental
stuff that I've wanted to touch on and a
little bit about the state of
California,
this highly regulated,
highly tax state that we're in and all
kinds of stuff,
but first you live in Berkeley.
I do.
What the hell is going on or what's
going on there?
It seems like it's become one.
You know,
it was once the home for free speech and
real liberalism and it seems like it's
become this sort of hysterical,
crazy silencing mob up there.
What's happening?
I mean in some ways it's funny because
it's,
it's supposed to be an outlier,
but in some ways it's similar to what's
happening in the rest of the country.
People aren't,
don't listen to each other.
You know,
it's so striking.
I think that the social media gives
people a lot of confidence in their
reviews.
They have a lot of information available
to them and so people are just not
listening and I find that everywhere.
You Know,
Berkeley is certainly the case.
We've been smug for a long time though
in Berkeley we pioneered it,
but have you seen a change
say in the last five or 10 years,
has something actually changed or was
this all just sort of what's happening
nationally?
I mean when I,
when I sort of changed my views in
particular of nuclear and dealt with
some of the backlash against that,
that gave me a different point of view
on the broader kind of culture and the
ways in which people are intolerant to
don't want to hear it,
but you know,
just because of my age I think and I
hadn't been associated with the
university.
I had a think tank in Oakland,
lived in Berkeley,
but I hadn't really had a lot of
interaction with the students until
recently so I didn't even know about
trigger warnings like into like a couple
of years ago.
And I was like what are those?
So live in Berkeley had a think tank in
Oakland.
I'm just trying to think for the people
that don't know,
you know,
you come from the left,
the area and all that stuff.
So before we get into the nuclear stuff,
which is really,
I think your,
your,
your key thing.
Tell me just a little bit about your
history.
What do I need to know about you before
we get into the meeting?
Let's see.
So I'm a gen x or a born 19,
71.
Raised you in that fear of the Cold War
as you probably had,
you know,
saw the day after on television when I
was in whatever,
12 terrified of nuclear war.
My parents were Christian pacifists,
but they also divorced.
So I was a kid of divorce,
a suburban Colorado.
I'm very left wing kid,
you know,
I had very,
my parents were pretty liberal and then
I moved to the bay area after college to
work with a left activist group called
global exchange.
So it was always.
I've always been sort of a man of the
left and when my views of nuclear in
particular change in the environment,
then I sort of was able to kind of start
to give myself permission to rethink
other things and not not believe
everything I thought so to speak and to
start to question some of those things.
Yeah.
And that's why I thought you'd be a
perfect guest because what we're about
to talk about now,
your sort of evolution and know you're
pushing against and where are you get
support.
It sort of fits a lot of sort of where
I'm at and a lot of what some of my
other guests who have dealt with.
So tell me as,
as you woke up to nuclear.
Alright.
So what was the sort of base
environmental thinking when you just got
out of college and we're working in?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean I had sort of that sort of basic
simplistic kind of lefty view that all
of the problems in the world due to big
corporations and capitalism and that
that's what was wrong with the
environment.
And I had this picture I think that a
lot of people have still,
which is that a more beautiful world
would be solar panels on your roof and
electric car in the driveway.
And um,
and we wrote about how to achieve that.
But the more we were writing about it,
the more we realized the limitations of
solar and wind in particular as energy
sources.
And we had a bunch of friends who were
just like,
you know,
if you're concerned about climate change
and air pollution,
why not nuclear?
And we had to go through a process,
really took several years to sort of
finally answered that question and go,
yeah,
we got to have nuclear,
we're going to deal with climate.
Yeah.
So before we fully get there,
what are some of the limitations?
Because I think most people,
even now,
even though you're saying this was a
couple of years ago for you sure now
most people I think have that idea if we
just all had solar panels on our roof
and if you'll,
if we had more wind turbines and all
that,
then everything actually would be okay.
But that's actually not what you argued.
That's right.
And it's in and my views sort of have
evolved,
but the biggest problem that people are
aware of is that you only get
electricity out of wind and solar when
the sun is shining and the wind is
blowing.
And um,
people kind of go,
well maybe there the sun is shining when
the wind's not blowing or the way you
know.
And it's like,
no,
that's not really true either.
So you always have to have power plants
ready to run at any minute.
I'm usually natural gas because you can
fire them up so quickly and people go,
what about batteries?
Batteries are really expensive.
Just getting enough of them to store the
amount electricity you need.
I mean I think we had.
We calculated that if you took all of
the batteries in California and you
stored all of electricity would have
like a couple of hours Max,
you know,
so and that would be taken all the
batteries out of cars and trucks.
So it's a lot of that.
A lot of batteries.
Yeah.
I think these batteries are terrible for
the environment and there's another
problem with renewables which is that
they take a lot of space because the
sunlight and water and wind are energy
diffuse.
There's just.
You have to get a lot of wind to get
enough electricity out of them or you
have to cover a lot of area to get
enough concentrated sunlight to make
sufficient quantities of electricity.
You actually have big land use impacts
and if the whole point is to save the
natural environment,
you end up doing things like a lot of
desert tortoises in the mojave and then
you have a big waste problem that we
haven't solved.
Both solar panels and batteries contain
high levels of toxic waste.
In fact,
about two to 300 more toxic waste from
the same amount of energy in solar
panels then is created from nuclear,
so when you kind of.
It's really the big problems with
renewables are actually environmental
problems and it also tends to make them
more expensive.
Do you think then that there's no place
for them or is there some place like if
if you were to drive from La here,
if we were to drive towards like palm
springs,
there are in the hills you see plenty of
wind turbines.
Obviously here in la because of the
amount of sunshine,
we see plenty of people with solar
panels on their roof.
Every time I go to home depot there's
only five people that try to accost me
and get me on panels and all that.
Do you think there's any place for those
things?
Oh,
sure.
And there's there,
there's one place for them as in my
backyard.
I have,
um,
you know,
I mean,
I think that solar was traditionally
used for remote applications,
so places where you don't have
electrical wire or it doesn't make sense
to have electrical wire,
their solar panels are really cool
technologies.
I mean,
there's nothing wrong with them.
I think there's something wrong when we
are subsidizing the most affluent
members of our society to have.
Um,
and that's what's happened.
So California has seen our electricity
prices went up 40 percent,
um,
at a period where,
I'm sorry,
they went up four times more than they
did in the rest of the country over the
last seven years.
And a big part of that was we were
subsidizing people to get solar and
wind.
I think if you're doing some
experimental work,
some r and d perfectly important role
for the government.
That's how we got jet turbines and a lot
of the technologies in our iphones.
But when you're kind of constantly
subsidizing them,
the people that get punished is working
people,
middle class people,
poor people because their electricity
prices go up and so that,
that starts to have a,
a,
a concern that a universal concern,
whether you're liberal or Conservative,
whatever.
So I want to get a little more to that
and government's role in whether that's
the answer will,
we'll show that for now.
But I'm very much aware of that because
even right now is I've looked into it a
little bit,
you know,
I see that a lot of subsidies have
actually run out in California.
There's a lot that are expiring at the
end of the year and all sorts of other
stuff.
And also just by a function of having
this studio,
I mean,
you see all these lights,
like these lights,
they burn hot and they suck a ton of,
uh,
of electricity.
So my electricity bill is there are,
are crazy.
So this is something I'm very aware of.
So Tony,
tell me when you started realizing that
nuclear wasn't the evil thing that
perhaps it had been portrayed.
As
you know,
I,
I think,
I mean I helped to stop a proposed
radioactive waste repository.
Actually I'm in my late twenties,
but as he got concerned about climate,
um,
you started hearing people talk a little
bit more about it.
I think my views are probably softening
even before I became directly focused on
it,
but then it was really a couple of
friends.
One of them was stewart brand who is
sort of the originary Hippie,
you know,
whole earth catalog.
I'm advisor to Governor Brown in the
seventies.
He wrote a famous essay in 2005 and then
a book in 2009.
And by the time I read the book in 2009
was pretty persuaded because he just
went through all the evidence,
you know,
the accidents really.
We're not what people think they are.
The waste is actually the best kind of
waste because there's hardly any of it.
It's easy to manage,
never hurts anybody.
What do they do with the waste?
Because I think that's what we usually
think of.
Think of the nuclear power plant and the
simpsons and the three items for damage
for your argument.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Anything else out there you have the
first thing you learn as you go.
Oh wait,
the waste isn't green and liquid because
it was in the simpsons,
which is how I got my information.
Yeah.
And Mr Burns was running for governor,
which.
Oh yeah,
there you go.
A little bit more money than I got,
but um,
you know,
now what we do with it is fine.
I think we take it.
You take the spent fuel,
you take the fuel rods out of the
nuclear reactor,
you cool them in water for a few years
and then we put them in dry cask storage
right there on the site where the plant
is from an environmental point of view,
that's like exactly what you'd want.
I mean,
if you,
when you grow up kind of learning about
the environment,
the first thing you learn is that waste
always has to go somewhere,
right?
It doesn't disappear and you have to be
responsible for taking care of the waste
products from our consumption.
So that's nuclear is like the only way
that we make electricity that does that
right now we don't have any protections
that solar panels won't just go into
landfills and leach toxic chemicals or
be sent to Bangladesh to be torn apart
by kids in slums.
I'm only nuclear really cares for its
waste and it's almost and really
clinical way.
We put them in these big casks and,
and they're right there on basically a
couple of basketball courts,
um,
at a given plant.
Um,
and we kind of look at them and store
them and watch them and people go,
what if they leak or something?
They're in these hugely thick cast.
But even if they were,
you would be able to see it and observe
it and there's not really anything to
lead because there's no way.
So is there any evidence that something
could really go awry with that as you're
laying it out as something that's pretty
safe?
No,
there's no evidence that waste from
nuclear energy production has had any of
those problems.
People say people point to problems with
the waste that came out of weapons
production,
but that,
that is a very different process.
You're just creating huge amounts of
plutonium and highly enriched uranium
for bombs.
And when we were really,
when you had really big problems even
there,
it was like in the middle of World War
II where you're just throwing bodies and
machines to fight this war.
So,
um,
it's got an incredibly good track
record.
I mean,
people will talk about wanting to bury
it under the desert in Nevada.
My.
And I'm always like,
I don't know why,
like why do you need to do that?
Like,
just,
it's fine where it is,
you just store it and maintain it.
It takes up no space.
It doesn't pose any harm.
Um,
for me,
I'm like,
that's like the one of the chief selling
points of nuclear is the way it manages
this way.
Yeah.
So when they talk about that,
you know,
burying it in the desert somewhere
underground or whatever,
are they talking more about the weapons
grade
and about the nuclear energy waste?
And I tried to figure it out because I'm
like a bit of a newcomer to it.
I didn't know.
I'm just,
I'm glad I asked people in the industry,
why do you need to do that?
And they kind of go,
well,
because it's better because it's better.
Look,
people made a lot of money building that
big hole in Nevada,
you know what I mean?
From a libertarian point of view,
you kind of go,
there's just,
there was a lot of money to be made on
these fears that were manufactured and
that we're used to manipulate people
like us.
I grew up in the seventies so that you
would think that there's some
relationship between like a bomb going
off and the waste and there's just
nothing.
The waste can't be used in that way.
Um,
so I have to say it's one of the things
I find most frustrating and baffling,
you know,
is it also one of those things that you
really.
And this is why I want to tag it on the
show to,
to really unpack this stuff.
You really have to have some basic
understanding of how this will work.
So when you even mentioned before that
the different ways between weapons grade
and just,
you know,
civilian use for power,
I don't think people have any sense that
these are different things
right now.
I don't know a lot about it and the
funny thing is,
so I'm working on a um,
I've got a book that I'm going to,
I'm doing on the history of nuclear and
one of the surprising things is that
ordinary folks knew that there was a big
difference between nuclear weapons and
nuclear power plants from like the mid
fifties to like the mid seventies,
like people kind of,
in fact the whole people were actually
excited about nuclear power.
Like they were like,
this is great.
You mean like this thing that's really
terrible and frightening actually has
this really positive side.
And I was like,
yeah,
well let's get some of that positive
side going because all we hear about is
the negative stuff.
This makes sense.
I was born in 76,
so right when that ended probably.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
a three mile island accident occurred
and blown way out of proportion,
but really importantly,
China Syndrome,
this,
this anti nuclear movement,
1979 came out and that really shaped
perceptions and,
and that they deliberately and you can
see what they're doing constantly.
They were trying to mix up the two
things.
Same word,
you know.
Um,
but you know,
it's funny because we have a lot of
dangerous things in our society that we
actually use for positive things were
even injecting polio virus into people's
brains to kill cancer particular kind of
cancers.
Um,
you know,
we obviously immunizer we inject our
children with dangerous diseases because
to protect them.
So I think we're capable of having a
more complex understanding of that
technology,
but there is vested interests and
ideological interests in maintaining
people's fears.
Right?
So there's sort of two separate things
here.
There's one is what the reality is.
And then there's the other where when
you hear about three mile island
Chernobyl or any of this stuff,
what's the argument that you're your
best argument when there's something
that actually is a disaster in the case
of turnover?
I guess you're saying three,
not as bad as they hyped it up to me.
Yeah.
So I mean there's three serious
accidents that involve melted reactors.
Three Mile Island,
Chernobyl,
and Fukushima,
the worst was Chernobyl.
And even the worst one killed shockingly
few people.
Mo basically killed the firefighters who
put out the fire about 50 to date.
Um,
and you know,
firefighters die putting out fires,
you know,
so it's not like unique to nuclear
accidents.
There were um,
uh,
was about a one percent mortality for
the several thousand people that got
thyroid cancer.
And then that's it.
Like no increase in any other cancers.
So nothing else.
Nothing else you would have asked me,
just not knowing anything about this.
I think I probably would have said,
oh,
there's probably like some sort of even
generational thing going.
No,
no,
definitely not.
That's,
I think that's really the,
the meme that's out there,
that's the one that they even promoted
it a lot was that somehow they were
like,
if you got exposed to radiation than
your kids would have some problems and
we don't see that.
And that's great.
I mean,
it's one of those things where everyone
should have been like,
Yay,
Yay.
We discovered that nobody was harmed,
let's celebrate.
But people were like,
no,
there's got to be something wrong.
I mean,
I think there's also just,
it is such a different way of making
heat.
That's what nuclear plants do.
They make heat and it heats,
used to make electricity.
Um,
but there's no smoke,
there's no fire,
there's no smoke.
And that's just weird.
I mean,
humans have been around for 200,000
years and we really evolved and our,
and our prehuman ancestors helped to
make us with fire.
So fire is just a central part of human
stories around the world and a central
part of our identity.
And we look at the Greek myths and then
we have this completely different way of
making energy and power and fire.
And I just think I'm not fire energy and
power and,
and we kind of go.
It's strange and I think we kind of go,
there's gotta be something wrong with
it.
Um,
and of course,
you know,
you get really close to nuclear
reactors,
it's really dangerous,
harmful and you can die.
So it's not like it's harmless,
but I think people don't understand,
you know,
when you consider that,
somewhere between five and 7 million
people die every year from just
breathing,
smoke and suffering,
respiratory illnesses.
I think we just are less scared of smoke
then,
then we should be part of it though,
that we're,
there's something about nuclear power
and when we related to weapons in our
minds,
it's become like this thing where we
love disaster movies,
you know,
all of this stuff.
So it's sort of taken a life unto its
own in a way.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it's such an interesting problem because
on the one hand people like,
they want so much safety from nuclear
even though it like kills,
like basically nobody,
you know,
compared to like every other way of
making energy mean natural gas pipelines
explode all the time.
Oil Refineries go down and it's kind of
like,
come on,
you know,
you drive your car super fast,
you smoke cigarettes when you get,
when you drink,
when you drink too much,
you know,
we do all these risky behaviors and
somehow we don't want any risky behavior
from this one.
I think it is that association.
You think something horribly could go
wrong.
Even though we've seen horrible things
go wrong with nuclear accidents and it
doesn't harm our laney buddy.
So,
you know,
I think it's about a lot of different
things.
Um,
you know,
I also,
it was interesting,
I saw,
I was watching one of your earlier
conversations where one of your guests
talked about the infantilization of the
public,
you know,
mean here we're rich and comfortable and
where we want like high levels of
safety.
I think the other thing that happens as
we've become developed and civilization
is that our fantasies of what could go
wrong get even more crazy.
Like,
you know,
I mean just the crazy things that people
thought about with genetically modified
foods,
you know,
these kind of scenarios that we concoct,
it's different from.
It is 100 years ago.
I mean,
when you're trying to deal with the
cholera epidemic or a polio epidemic,
you're not,
you don't need to fantasize about
horrible things going wrong.
You're watching them happen.
It's interesting.
I'm not going to remember this story
totally correctly,
so I have a feeling you'll be able to
clean it up.
But I grew up in long island and there
was a power plant either that was coming
or that they wanted to move her saying
Indian point.
Does that sound right?
Sure.
Um,
yeah,
insurance they were,
they wanted to build the shore on one.
They did finish the Indian point one.
Okay.
So I remember just around that,
all the,
I think I was maybe around 12 or
something and I remember hearing about
it all the time and that's when the
phrase Nimby got in my head,
you know,
not in my backyard.
And just this endless hysteria that
people were talking about that,
you know,
we're all gonna,
tumor has growing out of our head and
all this craziness.
And I guess you're saying there's no
evidence for any of that.
No.
And you know,
it's always like those panics that occur
and I think you have to consider it as a
panic.
It's always about something else,
you know,
there's something going on in the
society.
I mean,
the people that,
it's not everybody that was equally
afraid of nuclear plants,
right?
It's a particular people that have
particular views of the world and that
are suspicious of the government,
suspicious of corporations and the
system.
I'm suspicious of modern life.
And so,
um,
they're the ones that were more prone to
have those kinds of fears.
I think we see something different on
the conservative side of the political,
right.
They have different fears,
um,
you know,
that.
And if they express themselves
differently.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So when you start having this sort of
wake up to nuclear and you're in this
pretty lefty field in the geographic
places that,
in what kind of pushback did you get?
Oh,
a lot.
I mean a lot.
I mean and,
and it's.
And it's continued,
although I have to say it's gotten a lot
better.
I mean we saw one of the big
environmental online magazines just came
out with a long article and supportive
nuclear.
The I was in a documentary film that
came out of 2013,
so it's been now,
you know,
five years almost.
And that's how long these things take
for people to kind of calm down and look
at the evidence and you just get up
every morning and you continue to
advocate and,
and people,
you know,
facts still matter.
They matter.
Yeah,
I think they do.
I mean,
I think,
I think you still need time.
There's a way in which facts matter more
than ever because there's so much
opinion out there.
Everyone's got an opinion,
but you know,
real facts.
You kind of go,
look,
it's the World Health Organization.
Like do you think there's a conspiracy
involving thousands of scientists to
cover up some deaths that occurred?
I mean,
it just doesn't really make sense for
most people.
There's obviously a lot of conspiracy
theorists and crazy ideas,
but I think that a lot of people have
come around on the issue,
so a lot of my former guests had been
progressives that have sort of had a
kind of awakening and then they ended up
being hated by the very people they were
with.
Were you getting that?
Like,
I know I'm sure you were getting
pushback on the intellectual ideas,
but just I just want to sort of
understand because I think my audience
is surely attuned to this when you start
doing something a little bit different.
I just want to understand sort of the
level of hate and push back to you were
getting.
Yeah,
it was hard.
I mean,
you know,
you get a lot of.
I mean it's important to remind yourself
that sort of,
not about you,
you know,
because you've take it personally.
You're like,
well I'm not that kind of a person,
you know?
And it was like,
oh,
they're just projecting stuff onto you.
Um,
you know,
the most painful stuff was when I had a
friend on my facebook page accused me of
being on the take from the nuclear
industry and I was just kinda like,
look dude,
the friendship is like overnight.
And I was like,
that's.
But I didn't.
And he apologized later.
But it was an interesting interaction
because it was kinda like,
hey man,
you really kind of let yourself forget
who your friend was,
you know,
in this kind of,
is in the midst of all the Bernie
Sanders stuff,
or Bernie was attacking nuclear and he
was a big Bernie guy.
And I just remember being like,
you don't,
you're just caught up in something and
actually you need to kind of take us,
take a minute and get control and think
about what you're saying,
who you're saying it too.
And he apologized for it.
But I was kind of like,
how do you do that at like a mass level
where you kind of go,
hey,
everyone can be just a deep breath.
Take a deep breath.
And I love hearing that personal side of
it because I think so many people are
going through that,
not necessarily with,
with nuclear power like you're going
through it,
but just with whatever their own
political evolution is.
So let,
let's talk about Bernie and this for a
little bit because yeah,
he was campaigning against this.
Now if this,
if the science is as clean as what
you're saying is,
then why wouldn't the progressive,
you know,
lefty guy who's always talking about,
he's talking about and what does he say?
And environmental revolution writing
once a social revolution and a political
revolution in environmental.
He wants environmental justice.
I don't even know what that means.
Right?
But why wouldn't he be for this?
That's a very interesting question.
Um,
and I suspect there's a lot of different
reasons.
I mean,
some of it is he's an old guy,
you know,
it was very hard for old people to
change.
It was hard for me to change my mind
about nuclear and I was in my life like
late thirties,
early forties.
And again,
you have to overcome a whole bunch of
associations.
You know,
there's basically a picture what a lot
of it gets called environmentalism
doesn't have any to do with the
environment.
It has more to do with the kind of
society you want.
And so the idea would be we should have
decentralized food and energy
production.
You know,
we're all going to have our own little
chicken coop and our own little garden.
I got a solar panel.
There you go.
You're a part of it.
My kids aren't laying there like 18
weeks right now.
Now I can have an egg be one at the end
of this aisle.
Yeah,
I mean we,
you know,
we have a little garden in the back and
the amount of money and labor we put
into that garden,
I'm like,
each tomato is like $500,
you know.
So,
you know,
it's a bit of that fantasy.
I mean I,
you know,
I love working in the garden,
right?
Like it's great to work in the garden.
It's great to have fresh eggs and you
know,
and,
and for people that can afford it and
you might want it,
it might be cool to have solar panels
for a variety of different reasons.
I think that when you kind of get too
caught up in that and you start to think
that I'm going to produce all my food,
that way,
you know,
where I'm going to lose all my energy
that way that you really started to lose
touch with kind of a basic understanding
of how materials and energy and society
works and you're letting that desire for
a fantasy to take over.
So that's kind of what we come up
against.
I think that that's where if you can
kind of get people out of their own life
and their own how they want to live in
their backyard to well,
how are we gonna you know,
there's 7 billion people on earth,
so how are we going to provide food and
resources for everybody that helps to
recontextualize things.
So what's the connection there between
or what's the disconnect I should say,
between sort of progressivism and using
nuclear power?
Because what you're saying is this can
bring more energy to people that are
lower cost than a lot of the other
things that we're using it as a safer
level and it seems to me that even
though,
yes,
Bernie is an old guy,
it seems like this is something he
should,
should have come around on.
So I'm still missing that disconnect.
Maybe.
Maybe we just don't know.
Yeah,
I'm more.
Or is there something about the way the
lefties with environmentalism that's so
connected now to solar and wind and
stuff like that?
Well,
and it's funny because it all actually
happened here in California and you can
see the difference between our current
governor,
Jerry Brown and his dad.
His Dad was governor and he was what he
was the Democratic Party that I kind of
was raised on as the kids are the party
of the people,
you know,
it was a party for the working man,
the working family.
Everyone gets a high wage.
You build highways,
agriculture factories.
Um,
the sixties occur.
His son gets elected.
Jerry for the first time,
1974,
it takes part 1975.
And He,
and he says,
he's interviewed by William F Buckley,
actually.
He says,
we all have to do with less.
We need to have less material
consumption.
We have to obey.
Limits was a striking thing to be to
hear from not just who he was as a
Democrat,
as someone that was up for everybody
prospering,
but it was also.
He's one of the wealthiest families in
California.
They owned a huge oil monopoly from the
Indonesian military dictatorship.
So who was the one who were the people
that were promoting this idea of doing
with less?
It was the wealthiest members of our
society.
It was often kids that inherited family
wealth.
They had land.
And so one of the most surprising things
running for governor as I learned more
about the state,
is our housing crisis is a direct
consequence of that same worldview that
took over left liberal politics in the
seventies.
Before that,
the idea was there should be abundant
housing.
People should be able to buy a home.
And home ownership was really very
progressive,
right?
Because homeowners have so much wealth
in their homes and progressive's wanted
to promote that.
Well Jerry Brown gets in and his anti
development,
you know,
so called environmentalists get in there
and they seek to restrict homes,
housing,
consumption,
energy and it was almost like,
it was like almost the opposite of what
came before it.
So you're telling me that first term,
Jerry Brown is the guy I have to blame
for the mortgage that I'm going to be
paying for the rest of my life on this
thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
and really the.
I mean he's now sort of four terms when
he leaves office at the end of this year
and right at the beginning of next year
I should say.
Um,
and yeah,
I mean,
and it's again,
you kind of go,
well then why did,
why was jerry like that?
I mean that's where in my book I kind
of,
you kind of are like searching for it
and I think you just kinda get to a
backlash against basic progressive and
liberal lists.
And I mean that's the funny thing you
get.
There's a backlash against making
prosperity for all.
They didn't want everybody to have
prosperity.
They want it to really kick away the
latter.
And kind of protect all of it for
themselves.
Right.
So it's so interesting.
So you're saying basically in 75 he's
going,
well we're going to have to deal with
less,
but he didn't really mean we,
he may know because oil guys and
obviously the guys had a lot of money
and power for a long time through his
family because he's,
he's still around 30 some odd years
later.
Um,
I want to talk a lot more about what,
why you want to be governor.
But one other thing,
have you read that book right there by
any chance?
Of course.
And I know Alex,
I had a coffee with them.
Yeah.
Okay,
great.
So,
so Alex Epstein I had him on.
It's the,
the,
the case.
The moral case for fossil fuels is the
book I hit him on probably about two
years ago.
I don't think that I've ever gotten more
hate for an interview then.
I mean,
I've had plenty of controversial people
on here that I then get lumped in with
and people think I endorse all their
abuse,
which obviously is nonsensical,
but I truly think I got the most hate I
ever got for having this guy.
Now he's basically,
his basic argument is the title of the
book and he's just saying the most you
can do for humans now is to still use
fossil fuels.
I'm curious where you fall on that
argument.
I think he gets it half right.
I mean,
my view is that it's very.
my view is very simple in some ways.
I mean,
I think people.
I think now that I know more about
housing and schools and other things,
I'm like,
well that's really complicated stuff,
but energy,
I think it's pretty simple.
So most of us start off in societies
using wood and Dung as our primary
energy.
Anything is better than that,
including burning coal,
right?
Because it's terrible.
You breathe the smoke and and it's just
the Labor involved,
right?
So then you get electricity from coal
and hydroelectric dams.
Those are the first in poor countries.
Get so it was really a moral case for,
for coal and hydro if all you're using
is wouldn't dung,
but then I also think there's a moral
case for using cleaner burning fuels
like natural gas and uranium.
Um,
so,
so he wants to,
I mean,
Alex did a good job with this book in
the sense that he wanted to start a
conversation about why or when it
stopped poor countries from using fossil
fuels.
That's really unethical.
Um,
but I think you should go the other step
to say,
look,
there's,
even if you don't worry about climate,
there's air pollution,
there's other impacts of fossil energy
use and if we've got this fantastic
alternative and usually we go from coal
to natural gas and then to uranium than
we should keep going,
you know,
it's energy transitions and these energy
transitions,
which I don't want to get too much of my
campaign,
but these energy a little bit.
I do energy transitions.
Um,
you know,
when you go from horse and Buggy to
internal combustion engines and trains
are what drives those transitions from
energy sources.
So you go from wood and dung to coal and
partly because of trains but also
factories and whatnot.
And then I think you eventually get to a
electric powered world electric cars,
electric heating,
um,
as we move towards nuclear.
Okay.
So we've hit than solar.
We pit when,
let's just do two of the others.
You mentioned one of them right there.
Uh,
so let's just talk about natural gas.
What do we need to know about natural
gas generally?
Um,
I mean,
the first thing to know is that just
like on so many of the things,
Americans are just the luckiest people
in the world.
I mean,
we have so much oil and gas.
It's just incredible,
like a huge amount of our wealth in the
last decade came from this fracking
revolution,
which of course environmental supposedly
hate,
although in many ways they really like
it.
That was going to be my second one to
ask you,
but I really,
I'm really asking the same question,
right?
So,
um,
you know,
I think there's two things I think are
important to know about natural gas.
The first is that it's just way better
than coal,
like we went and looked at all the
scientific peer reviewed research and
it's just on every measure.
Water use,
water pollution,
air pollution,
carbon emissions,
everything.
Gas is just better than coal.
Of course it is,
right?
You're using your kitchen and it's safe.
Yeah,
I mean still explode sometimes.
Cultural,
they want to talk to you about the
exploding.
Yeah.
Um,
and it's not as good as uranium which we
use for nuclear.
Um,
similarly on all the same metrics,
uranium performance better.
So there's a way in which I just kind of
go,
there's just,
this is just basic energy density.
This basic physical facts about these
fuels makes there,
makes a progression exist wood to coal,
to oil to natural gas.
You rainium.
Um,
I think,
I think it's important to know,
and I think one of the challenges I
often make to my libertarian friends is
that the government played a very
positive role in all of these energy
technologies.
Um,
uh,
maybe with the exception of,
um,
of coal,
although there's a little bit there,
but you really,
um,
oil and gas,
the US government has constantly been
supporting r and d nuclear came out of a
military weapons program.
Um,
uh,
so I think that,
you know,
when you think about these energy
transitions,
I think there is a role for government
because there is a public benefit in
terms of moving towards cleaner fuels
and also faster and better
transportation.
Yeah.
So let's just do fracking because every
time you say fracking,
people think of,
you know,
the fire coming out of their faucet.
They think of,
to make another simpsons reference.
They think of burns is slant oil
drilling company that almost destroyed
springfield.
Is that what fracking?
Um,
you know,
the funny thing is the sort of famous a
fire,
the famous a water faucet on fire scene.
We now,
I think we now think came from a much
older natural gas.
Well,
I'm not from fracking and um,
and the fracking itself is just breaking
up the Rock,
the shale rock and allowing the gas to
escape.
That's not the stuff that you would
worry about
if you cared about the environment,
which you worry about is the disposal of
the water and the sealing of the,
um,
of the,
of the pipes where the gas comes out.
Um,
so the thing is people tend to worry
about or think about.
I think you just got tied up with the
word fracking as well,
which sounds like a bad word,
but the funny thing is like,
I'm just like,
you know,
coal has actually gotten cleaner over
the years.
Natural gas has gotten cleaner over the
years.
Oil burning cars,
everything is cleaner and better.
Um,
but never as good as that next cleaner
energy source.
So the better way to think about it,
I think as we get caught up in like how
do you get the gas and whatever,
you need to have some protection of the
environment and the public.
But really the main event is to move
from these dirty,
your energy sources to cleaner ones.
Okay.
So let's talk about your campaign for
governor of the Great State of
California.
You were a lifetime Democrat and as you
said,
your parents were progressive,
left these liberals.
Uh,
but you're running as an independent.
I'm running as a democrat.
Oh,
you are running.
It did change.
It did.
Dodo.
I,
uh,
when I announced I saw some resident
dependent and I,
and I was and am frustrated and upset
with the Democratic Party.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
I was raised like this was like the
party of the people.
That was what my parents taught me and
that's what I believed and it has been
completely taken over by basically
landlords and energy companies and
special interests.
And in California and things have gotten
worse,
not better.
Highest poverty rate in the country,
highest taxes.
Those two things aren't supposed to go
together.
Those were supposed to go the other way.
Exactly.
You're just going to have the highest
taxes then you should have of
Massachusetts,
levels of poverty and if you're going to
have the highest levels of poverty,
then you just have like no tax or
something.
Right?
So something's really wrong with the
party.
And you know,
I'm a little bit like going from that
scene,
from the abyss when Ed Harris takes his
ring off and he like throws it in the
toilet because he's so upset with his
marriage.
I felt a little bit like that at the
Democratic Party.
It was like just,
you know,
and then I kind of fished it out of the
toilet,
you know,
put it back on my hand.
And I was like,
okay,
if I'm going to do this,
not only do I have to,
you know,
become governor,
we also have to clean up the
legislature.
You have to get a serious reformers in
and we've got to reform the Democratic
Party because it's just not responsive
to the people.
Maybe abyss reference in politics is
works for me.
Good.
Okay.
Howard,
that ship let's just.
Exactly.
It had to be at the alien ship by the
way.
Not to mention the alien ship fusion.
Wait.
So okay.
So you originally said Independent.
Now I get your frustrations with the
Democrats watching this understands I'm
with you on that.
What,
what caused you to shift?
Was that purely a tactical?
It's just even back to Democrat.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's,
it's a little bit like it's probably
more emotional and sort of about just
who I am and just kind of being like not
wanting to give up on this thing that I
believed in.
You know,
like I said,
I think the Democratic Party up until
like 1975 was right on a bunch of stuff.
It started getting really crazy after
that and frankly started becoming kind
of the opposite of what it was supposed
to be.
Particularly in California.
It became really an aristocratic party
we've put in place and almost a feudal
system in this state where you have just
a huge number of very wealthy people.
We subsidize a small number of lottery
winning poor people who basically work
as the servant class for the rich and
then we drive the middle class people
out of the state and,
and that is not what the Democratic
Party was about before 1975.
And you truly are not being hyperbolic
about this because just as someone that
bought a house in the last year that the
house prices,
and you referenced this earlier about
the housing crisis,
the house prices are,
are legitimately insane.
Where I used to live,
uh,
now I'm in a cheaper area here,
I don't want to say exactly where,
but where I used to live in west
Hollywood to get literally a one
bedroom,
one bathroom house that wasn't
completely dilapidated,
literally a million dollar.
Oh yeah,
no,
I mean,
look in 2011 when Jerry Brown took
office,
over half of Californians could afford a
middle class home today,
just 28 percent can millennials in
California,
only a quarter own homes.
And the rest of the country it's over 50
percent.
So if you're a millennial or renter,
uh,
you work for your salary,
um,
you're on the losing side of how
California has got this set up.
I mean,
so that's why I'm running is I the more
I learned about the corruption and
really just the destruction of the
California dream,
you know,
which is,
which actually precedes the American
dream.
You know,
historically California dream was
opportunity owner home,
great schools,
beautiful weather.
We slowed the good weather when there is
in fire coming mudslide.
Oh no,
that's okay.
Um,
yeah,
so it's like the state is full of these
contradictions,
right?
We say we're the most progressive state,
but we have the highest poverty rate and
the highest levels of inequality.
You know,
we say we're the land of opportunity,
but we won't let people build homes.
You know,
we have this incredible gift which is
this tech economy.
Silicon Valley is really driving
economic growth,
not just in the state but in the country
and arguably around the world.
And yet like we won't let people build
like little apartment buildings are a
little,
little new subdivisions.
I mean we've got spectacular natural
areas that we're always going to
protect.
But here's the most stunning thing.
The biggest use of land and the state is
cattle ranching,
still like a 19th century economic
activity.
And we won't let people.
What?
We can't let people build a home because
of the cattle were putting cattle and
cows before middleclass people before
millennials that,
you know,
you and me,
a gen x,
we might be able to sneak in there.
We got our homes at the law we got in
before they shut the door finally.
But millennials are really in trouble
unless we can significantly expand
housing.
So what is the solution in terms of
taxes?
It seems to me,
I've only been in La for five years.
I'm only a homeowner for,
or I've only been in California for five
years.
I'm only a homeowner for basically a
year.
We were taxed at incredibly high levels.
Uh,
obviously I'm not into that and as
you're saying,
the money that they're raising doesn't
seem to be doing the things in terms of
helping the people who need it the most
doesn't even really working.
How do you fix that and how would you
fix that from inside?
The machine that you're saying is
actually so corrupt?
Well,
this is the,
this was one of the most exciting parts.
I mean,
it was funny,
um,
because I was so focused on energy,
you know,
and then it was kind of,
okay,
I'm going to try to deal with,
look at California as a whole and my
brain's been hurting because there's so
much to learn,
but when you get a broader view of it,
you what you understood,
you have a broader picture that goes,
look,
we need high levels of economic growth.
You need high paying jobs.
That means that we can't.
We've got to stop losing good
manufacturing jobs to Texas,
you know,
we've got to get Toyota to stay here.
We got to get,
you know,
I mean really it's about supplying these
big multinationals,
Boeing and our apple making high value
products for the high value components
to those,
those products essentially
purely a tax break thing.
Is that purely the thesis?
Sometimes it's just infrastructure and
sometimes it's just having housing for
their workers.
Toyota took 3000 high paid executive
jobs from California to Texas because
they,
because they couldn't afford the
housing,
the executives were like,
look,
in Texas I can buy a house for much
less.
The median price home in California is
two and a half times higher than the
national average,
so just having more homes makes the
state more able to retain high paying
jobs.
So these things are all interconnected
in that way.
So housing,
sometimes just infrastructure,
you know,
like if an Amazon or a costco or
whatever,
if they need some infrastructure built
and it's a good deal,
we should be doing that.
And the reason that we're not is because
the leaders of our state and the leaders
of this party really don't believe in
it.
They really are about keeping California
expensive and elite to themselves.
I mean,
it's really a country club kind of
liberalism.
It's not.
It's really illiberalism.
So if Jerry Brown was sitting here and
heard you say that,
what,
what do you think is counter argument to
that would be.
He would say that he's been trying to
get housing built,
but he's just got these powerful special
interests.
I mean,
he says that he does say it directly,
so as the unions and the
environmentalist are opposed to it now,
I've looked closely at this question and
the truth is that most of the labor
unions,
especially like sci,
you or the Teachers Union,
70 percent of teachers can afford a home
in California.
I mean,
that's just scandalous.
Most of the unions want to see more
housing.
There's three unions,
tiny trade unions,
mechanics,
the mechanical,
electrical and plumbing,
which are basically working with the
anti development environmental
organizations to prevent a reform that
would very modest reforms that would
basically prevent frivolous lawsuits
under are very good environmental laws.
We have good environmental laws that are
being destroyed by people using them to
block housing projects for reasons that
have nothing to do with the environment.
In order to that they can manipulate the
projects,
get their way in a variety of ways.
Can you give me an example of one of
those?
Yeah,
I totally can.
I'm in Berkeley in my hometown,
uh,
the New York Times did a great piece on
it.
There is a single family home in
Berkeley that they wanted to a nice
sized lot.
They wanted to demolish the home and put
up three homes,
sort of switched them vertically and you
have a little driveway that would go in
and one of the neighbors have organized
against it.
I'm one of the reasons they gave is that
complain that it would cast shade on
their garden.
And it was like they have a photo of the
garden,
The New York Times and it's just the
most pathetic looking like,
I'm sorry,
like,
that was like that.
I don't even think those plants are
alive,
you know,
and like they were like,
well,
we use it to produce food for ourselves.
I was like,
if that were true,
you'd all be starving to death,
you know.
So stuff like that,
um,
you know,
there's sort of a question,
is it,
is it economically rational?
In other words,
if you allow another house get built,
will your property value decline?
I just don't think there's any.
Supposedly you've,
you have more supply,
the prices would go down,
but there's just so much pent up demand
for housing.
I don't even think that's the case.
So it's a lot of that petty stuff.
The unions use it a lot to,
to,
to get high wage project labor
agreements.
I'm in favor of high wages,
especially if you have such high housing
prices but,
but fundamentally you need a lot more
housing.
We need a least twice as much housing
built annually.
Then we're building just to keep pace
with demand.
Yeah.
Is there some argument though for that,
for that family that doesn't want the
shade in their backyard?
Even if the garden is nothing or
whatever like I can think to here in La,
you know,
in the Playa Vista area,
that's where youtube and Google is and
it was pretty much nothing there.
Then they put up all of this.
Now what is insanely expensive?
Um,
I mean I'm talking two or $3,000,000
for a town home,
not even for your own home with
virtually no property,
but that it seems to be.
There's some argument for the people
that did live there for 30 years that
don't want all of this monstrous stuff
around them.
My slogan,
I say this as someone that doesn't want
the government to mitigate all of that,
but you know,
and I guess,
look at the end of the day,
they might get bought out at a really
nice rate.
Right.
So that's.
So that would be good.
Yeah.
I mean my um,
the slogan that we're,
we're,
we're playing with is um,
give change a chance,
you know,
I mean here you live in a city.
Okay.
You know,
you're living in a city near mass
transit.
I mean,
you're in an industrial heavy,
you know,
your home has increased in value
dramatically and then you kind of go,
we'll know.
No one can make any change in my
neighborhood.
I mean,
I just think everybody is,
needs to be more reasonable.
I mean,
my basic view is like there needs to be
more housing everywhere in the cities,
in the suburbs protect our natural
areas.
They're fine.
Like there's so much land in the state,
plenty of land in the cities and the
suburbs.
Everyone just needs to be a bit more,
give a little bit more,
be a little bit more reasonable.
Um,
you know,
and the reforms that I'm talking about
are things were don't allow multiple
lawsuits against one project,
you know,
and make sure that you have to identify
yourself right now.
You can sue anonymously,
you know,
if you're gonna,
try to stop an important project to
house these really valuable workers.
I mean,
here we have brought people from all
around the country,
all around the world who are these
talented technology programmers and
marketing type people or whatever.
And then we say to them,
oh,
you have to pay $4,000
a month for a one bedroom,
you know,
and if they want to buy a home,
we say,
you're out of luck.
You know,
I,
it's just,
that's not what the California dream was
about.
It wasn't about,
I got mine and now forget everybody
else.
The California dream was expansive.
It was,
it was said,
hey,
you know,
this is a,
an amazing state in the greatest state,
in the greatest country in the world.
We've got to be more open.
So I sense basically you want lower
taxes basically.
Right?
Which is,
that's going to put you at somebody with
the Democrats.
Yeah,
I mean,
on the taxes.
Let's talk about taxes.
I mean the first thing you have to
understand is that like there's sort of
like,
what would I do if I could start with a
blank piece of paper?
You know,
and then there's like,
okay,
if you become,
when you become governor,
you're immediately negotiating with all
these different interests.
And by interests I don't mean just even
organized interest groups.
I just mean like homeowners who are kind
of like,
you know,
don't want to change.
So there's a very famous law in
California,
probably no prop 13 passed in 1978 and
it restricts how much taxes can go up on
a home.
So if you bought a home for a half a
million dollars and it increased to a
million dollars in say five years,
you would only,
you can only,
they can only increase your taxes two
percent a year.
Um,
and um,
and you know,
the reason given a sort of a sound
sensible,
which is that you don't want to,
like,
you know,
someone for no fault of their own
selling,
their house is worth a lot and then
suddenly they're being hit with the tax
bill they can't afford.
So you basically,
even though you've had a great
investment,
you can't even afford your investment.
Yeah.
So I think that,
again,
I think there just needs to be some
reasonableness,
so it's considered the third rail of
California politics to even suggest
reforming prop 13.
But I think we do need to reform it.
And part of the reason is that our
current taxes are so lopsided with the
highest sales tax in the country,
the highest income taxes on the top
earners.
And you might go,
well that's progressive because they
have more money.
But the problem is,
is that every time the economy goes into
recession,
we're just in massive debt,
right?
So the when and then when we have a
surplus like we had this year,
it's because the stock market's been
going crazy.
So when the one percent,
so it's Kinda funny that people that are
like,
we got to tax the one percent more.
It's like,
well we've made the entire economy,
all of our schools,
you know,
all of these government services
completely dependent on the fortunes of
the stock market.
So we're a state founded on boom and
bust the gold rush.
But we gotta get more stability in those
finances.
So I think there's just got to be.
I think these things like housing reform
I think has to be done as a whole.
And I think similarly the tax and budget
form has to be done as a whole because I
think everybody,
it's a classic prisoner's dilemma,
right?
Where it's like,
well I'm not going to want to think of
anything and I'm going to stay on,
stay strong because,
you know,
make them get first.
So everyone's going to have to be.
I'm still like,
I don't know,
I can't make my slogan be a little bit
more reasonable,
but dogs.
Um,
but I think you've got to get,
I mean that's what you're supposed to do
as governor race was to bring to the
table,
kind of go look,
everyone's gonna need to make some
compromises and I don't think they're
that big.
I mean when you fly over,
I mean certainly la,
the bay area,
it's just a lot of single family homes,
like everywhere and you're kind of
like,
look,
you're right in the middle of the city,
you know,
you gotta allow like a four or five
story building to go up.
And similarly you see a lot of lawsuits
to block like additional homes in the
suburbs by the people that just had
their homes built in the suburbs.
You know,
it's always like,
oh yeah,
the last guy up the ladder is the one
that's like most fiercely kicking it
away.
Right.
Well,
West Hollywood that I mentioned before,
they put a moratorium.
They were building all these sort of
what they were kind of calling like
these mcmansions,
you know,
these very modern,
tall things.
And then they were basically dotting the
neighborhoods thus causing shade and
everyone else's.
They actually stopped them from doing it
for awhile I think.
I think it just expired.
So I mean you kind of go look,
you know,
you won the lottery.
You if you bought a home in California
anytime in the last,
you know,
30 years or you know,
even like you've probably seen your
prices even go up just one last year.
Look,
you've done really well like you've
made.
You've often male.
If you bought your home in like 2010,
let's say,
you know,
or,
or if you bought it in 2000 or 1990 or
1980,
you made a big chunk of money on your
home.
So then then to then turn around and
say,
well no,
my taxes shouldn't go up at all,
is just unreasonable.
It's like,
you know,
that's just not fair to everybody else
who comes in later.
You know,
they show you in my home,
I bought my home,
I pay 10 times more in taxes on my home.
Then the people that owned it prior,
you know,
I'm not saying that I shouldn't pay a
little bit more in taxes coming a little
bit later and uh,
know maybe a higher income,
but 10 times,
you know,
that's,
that's the part where it's kind of like,
what is it exactly going to be?
It's like you're going to have to
negotiate something that's just a lot
more fair than my current situation.
I like that you're kind of talking about
this in a holistic way because it seems
to me that you definitely still have
some progressive leanings,
which is totally fine,
but I can tell you also have some
libertarian leanings and I actually do
think that that's where most people
fall,
which is why I think that this sort of
interesting center that's developing
lately makes some sense.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
the market is absolutely amazing,
right?
And does so well on so many things.
It doesn't do everything,
you know?
I don't think it just seems to have to
be so extreme,
you know,
it's like,
um,
like I said,
like most of the major technologies and
the iphone came out of the Defense
Department,
you know,
jet turbines which allows us to do jet
travel,
came out of the military.
Um,
you know,
a lot of the technologies that are
making the environment better.
Um,
electric cars,
fuel cells,
these things are all supported by
government,
r and d when you're talking about 20
years of subsidies to industries that
are plowing money into campaign
contributions and the technology's still
aren't very good.
That's when you have real problems,
but it's almost impossible to beat that
machine,
right?
I mean,
that's really what you're up against
right there.
If you're going to really say we got to
stop subsidizing some of this massive
stuff and I suspect Jerry Brown probably
gets a lot of money from those guys and
just just that the machine itself has
existed for so long.
That's really what you're up again.
Well,
what's cool is that,
so when I got into this discovery,
this really this corruption scandal that
I think is really important,
but most people their eyes glaze over,
it involves the public utilities.
Everyone's like,
all
right,
but I just,
you know,
I mean what I learned about it is I was
like,
well,
how do public,
how do you,
how do you solve corruption?
Like there's a history here.
So what you discover is that there's
just these natural cycles of corruption
and reform and they've occurred several
times in the 20th century.
One of them occurred in the 19 twenties
and thirties and other one occurred in
the 19 seventies.
So I was like,
oh,
like we're overdue for another period of
reform.
I mean that's,
that's where it's,
I think people kind of go,
you're up against this huge machine.
And it's like,
yeah,
and if you knew how bad it,
if you knew how corrupt it was,
like I know you will be all about
overthrowing it.
Yeah.
Is that not though a purely libertarian
argument that it's like we keep going
through these phases,
then we put in new laws,
they gets better for a little while,
then it gets worse,
but that the libertarian argument would
be all right,
get rid of all these laws were extremely
overregulated here in California.
Get rid of all of this and let's just
see what the market actually does
because we just simply don't.
No.
Well,
you know,
you got for some things.
I think that makes sense.
And for others,
I don't think it does.
So there are natural monopolies,
um,
electricity things where you're just
doing a lot of infrastructure that is
very expensive and then you're kinda
like,
okay,
so we're gonna have two electric
companies like stringing of electric.
I mean like it's just,
that's how we got,
that's why we regulate electric
utilities and the way we do.
Um,
now some of them have been privatized,
but you're still,
you still have monopoly for the Poles
and wires.
Otherwise it's like,
it's already really ugly.
Like all the electrical wires,
you know,
you're an environmentalist,
like I'll bury those.
Um,
but,
but you know,
it's like,
oh no,
we're gonna have a whole second or third
set of electrical wires.
So the government was like,
look,
just you can have a monopoly and you can
even be a privately owned company but
you can't price gouge.
Right.
So like you're going to come to us and
go,
hey gotta raise rates.
And we kind of go,
oh,
okay.
So some of it's negotiated and just a
little bit messier.
Is there corruption?
Definitely some,
some extent.
Is it inevitable?
I think it is,
but I think it's inevitable meaning that
because of the way the system worked
there eventually,
even if they're being controlled a
little bit,
there's still the only game in town so
they can always keep ratcheting it up.
I mean like,
you know,
like Jerry Brown's father I think
achieved amazing things in California,
you know,
the universities,
the roads,
the water systems,
it was a period of high growth as well
and he benefited from was there some
political corruption in the sense of
doing so,
giving some contracts to sure you know,
what you want is to make sure it doesn't
become proportions like we see in the
developing world,
spend much time in central Africa or in
Latin America and you're just getting.
You get to the point where the
corruption is so severe that nothing
gets built.
Like at the end of the day it was
corruption and Korea where I spent a
bunch of time at the end of the day they
get the thing built.
You know,
in other places if you don't get a bill
and you're like,
well,
so I think we've just gotten to a point
where it's just gotten so excessive in
California,
the just the exchange of contributions
for contracts and permits has just got
to the place where it's just obscene and
needs to be fixed and as usual,
the best way to fix it.
It's just with sunlight and
transparency,
I mean,
you know,
they all have these really bad deeds can
only occur behind the cover of darkness.
And so once you shine a light on it,
it tends to take care of itself.
Sunlight is the best disinfectant it is.
That has been a theme around here.
So just tell me about a couple of the
other issues that you actually care
about that you're campaigning on.
Well,
one of the ones I'm really excited about
is education and you know,
what's,
what I love about going into an issue
that you're sort of new to.
I mean,
my mom is a public school teacher,
was a public,
was the teacher's Union Rep and my
sister is a,
is an education expert.
So it's certainly something we've talked
about for a long time,
but what's the fun to go back into it?
Associate fresh and you start to see
these fights and arguments between
people,
um,
from a,
from a different point of view.
I'm not participating in them,
but what was so striking for us when we
looked at the research was that what's
clear is that we've got the school
schedule that makes everybody unhappy,
right?
You go to school at like eight and then
you get out at like 2:30,
you know,
and like all the bad things as you,
as you and I know from our childhoods
occurs between 2:30
and when your parents come up and then
you have these after through the best
hours of like.
Exactly.
I don't.
Yeah,
I'm going to take them away.
That's the problem.
You know what I mean?
So I think schools have to work for
parents,
so it be nine to five,
like why is it you have to cobble
together afterschool programs and these
things and that is,
we're like,
often kids fall behind.
Um,
I also think the school year should be
longer.
Um,
and I think teachers want to be treated
like professionals.
There's nothing more demoralizing for
teachers than like bad teachers because
that's what my parents would come home
and complain about bad teachers all the
time.
So you've got to build to move out the
bad principals,
move out the bad teachers,
you've got to have a proper professional
school day.
And that first part though,
that's it.
That's a big fight you'd be taking
against it is absolutely.
Yeah.
And they've got to give.
I mean,
look,
the teachers are unhappy.
I mean the turnover rate is just through
the roof.
I mean,
like I said,
17 percent of them can't afford to live
here.
So.
So I do think teachers that are
performing should be paid better.
I think the school should be nine to
five.
I think the school year should be
longer.
What we know is that the more time that
kids get instructional time,
their performance goes up and our
performance in California has been going
down even though we put $20 million more
in the schools over the last seven
years.
And that's what seems to be one of the
places that again,
libertarian,
crazy California.
It's like you keep pumping money into
things,
but then every time we tested,
every time you look at the numbers and
we compare you state by state,
it's worse.
It's worse than it is,
it's frankly,
it's a scandal and the people that
suffer the most,
it's the usual,
the poor African Americans,
Latinos,
um,
performance has been flat line or even
declining.
And so because,
you know,
if you're,
if you're wealthy,
you know,
if you're privileged you can send your
kids to private summer science camp and
stuff like that.
So.
So I would like to see a significant
reform.
Again,
it has to go with taxes.
If you're going to go year round is
probably going to cost more.
How are we going to finance that?
Again,
you just got to have a wholesale reform
of taxes.
I think education,
what is exciting though,
is that a longer school day and a longer
school year,
it means you have more time to do the
instructional on math and science and
reading which kids need to get up to
snuff.
But then you also have the time for
stuff arts,
you know,
physical education.
We need to do more physical education
and then it allows for the dea.
I mean,
here we have a digital technology
revolution happening in this state that
we're leading and the place that it has
not penetrated at all is like the
schools,
I mean there's some amount of laptop
use,
but what you get with the digital
revolution is that you can be a so,
so math lecturer or teacher,
but the kids can get it now on Khan
Academy or they can watch Ted talks that
people that do a much better job
explaining it and then the teachers can
roam and be tutors.
My mom was also a tutor and when I was a
kid one time she tutored me and she
usually tutored learning disabled kids
and she treated me.
I was like,
wow.
It was like,
I learned so much in like an hour.
I was like,
tutoring works with all kids.
And she was like,
yeah,
tutoring works with everybody.
So you call it flipping the classroom.
Kids get the lectures from digital
devices,
chromebooks or,
or smart phones or just from TV's.
Um,
and then the teachers can roam and do
tutoring and then that allows,
that solves a big problem which is that
both the overachieving kids and the
underachieving kids are being neglected
as,
as teachers try to get the kids in the
middle to pass the tests.
It's an interesting concept because
there is so much information accessible
at your fingertips.
I mean the amount of people that watch
shows like this.
Just for some information.
My friend Greg Gutfeld,
he's been on the show,
wrote a great piece a couple of weeks
ago about how it's like all the stuff
that you're supposed to learn in college
that unfortunately now because of the
hysteria colleges that you're not
learning,
right?
You can go online and hear lectures from
incredible professors like Jordan
Peterson again said and listen to these
guys tell you all of the things that
they're supposed to be telling you at
college.
And guess what?
If Youtube,
it's free.
It's wonderful.
Wonderful.
I mean,
Khan Academy is this beautiful.
My daughter does it on her.
She has an iphone.
She's 12,
which I was a reluctant about,
but with what?
With Khan Academy,
these beautifully perfect lectures that
are designed to that we know that they
work,
the kids then interact with it.
You still need to have a role for people
because you need the interaction,
you need the group work between the
kids.
You knew the teachers going around.
But I mean we are just massively
underperforming as a country and as a
state when it comes to education,
we're getting our tails beat by,
by my much poor developing countries
like Korea.
Um,
the longer school I hear that and I
think suddenly I became a 12 year old
what I know about myself.
So what do you,
what do you actually mean by that?
Well,
I mean,
again,
I think cost is going to be something
we're gonna have to deal with because it
will,
it will almost certainly cost more
money.
So,
you know,
I'm Kinda like,
we've got a nine month year now.
I'd love to see us get to 11 months.
You know,
some parents don't want to take their
kids away for a month or you know,
travel around or whatever.
Just like overloading kids with
information because I think we're
generally,
because of our smart phones and twitter
and everything is we're in an
information overload.
What about the value of that two month
break that we had as children will.
The problem is is that during that break
was huge cognitive declines.
It's very well documented now that we
just.
Kids will forget a lot of stuff and then
you start the next school year and you
review for the first several weeks or
months.
The older stuff,
the kids that suffer the most are the
less affluent kids,
African American kids,
Latino kids whose parents don't send
them to science camp during the summer.
So,
but in terms of overloading the biggest
problem of the overloading is the school
day.
You're cramming all this stuff in
between like eight and two,
you know,
and so sometimes somebody will be like,
well what about like elementary school?
Like little kids need to take a nap,
you know,
it's like,
great,
take a nap.
Maybe the teachers could take an
attitude.
What about arts?
And so I think there should be more,
like,
as a writer,
I walk a lot,
I don't know how I could ever write
anything if I didn't just walk and think
about it.
So it should be more of,
there should be more downtime to respect
the fact that our brains get tired and
the kids need some time off and the
first part of the day's gonna be more
productive than the second part of the
day.
But if you have more time you can deal
with that.
The other thing is that I'm going to
eliminate homework and I'm going to
eliminate schoolwork for teachers.
So,
um,
so get yourself back in your 12 year old
mind.
No more homework.
All the homework is done at school.
Okay.
Because you were losing me a little bit
with exactly.
But now no homework,
no homework.
And then my mom would come home,
you know,
she would come home from school,
whatever it was,
4:00,
5:00,
make dinner,
and then she would go back to work
grading papers and preparing for lessons
like in the evenings when it should have
been family time.
Um,
and,
and I think that what I'd like to say to
teachers is just go,
look,
you get to leave work at work,
you get to be what everybody else gets
to do.
You go home from work and you're not
supposed to work anymore.
I get to watch television,
watch a movie with your kids and then
the kids too,
they get to leave the work at school and
so the homework and the school work,
the grading and the lesson plans,
all that gets done at school and is
opened up by having kids are able to get
a personalized digital education with
like the best world world's best
lecturers and teachers online.
So that's an interesting way of kind of
splitting the difference.
Okay,
we're going to extend this day.
Yeah.
Um,
which sort of goes against my feeling
about overloading,
but they were going to build things in
which are going to allow teachers to be
able to do some more work and students
to.
Absolutely.
I mean kids are kids used to learn how
to draw like properly,
right?
And we have like art classes,
but like who knows how to really just
draw,
right?
Like you look at the 19th century edgy,
you know,
you kind of go,
that might be one of the things that
gets taught again,
you know,
you have some more time to actually.
And there's also like a bunch of stuff
now about like you need that social and
emotional intelligence to perform well
in the business world and you know,
just to not be a jerk,
you know,
those are things that can all be taught,
but you need to have the time for it.
This thing of rushing in 45 minutes
through math and rushing for the minutes
of reading in history is,
is just a,
it's a,
it's based on,
uh,
you know,
when we were farmers,
and when we thought people were
preparing people for the factories,
now we know that we're all so different
and how we learn.
We're at different levels.
We can go at different paces.
I wasn't very good at math.
I was very,
I was pretty good at reading.
You can get an education that's really
tailored to you once you have that time
and you have to open up that digital
universe that already exists.
Yeah.
Give me a couple more.
Your,
your major thing.
So yeah,
so we went through,
so we went through housing,
we went through jobs and through schools
obviously energy,
cheap,
reliable,
clean energy is essential to be able to
bring back those good manufacturing
jobs.
There's,
you know,
people have the wrong idea.
They think,
oh,
the manufacturing has to go abroad,
high tech manufacturing needs to be
here,
but it needs cheap energy and it also
needs skilled workers.
So one of the other reforms that occurs
and as the relationship between the jobs
and the school's apprenticeship
programs,
you know,
young people want to have mentors,
they want to have masters that they
apprentice with will.
So let's get Boeing and apple to have
supplier companies here,
whether it's in the central valley or in
La and it should be,
have a direct relationship to the high
schools and the community colleges.
And then we need the cheap energy.
So we've got two nuclear plants.
They've shut down one of them through
and that's what led to the corruption
scandal that trying to shut down the
second one,
they,
they provide total 40 percent of our
clean electricity in the state.
I want to get them started back up
again.
People worry about the safety.
I think they shouldn't be worried,
but the other cool thing that's going on
is that they haven't made a lot of
progress in what are called accident
tolerant fuels,
fuels that if there is a loss of coolant
and as a risk of overheating,
it would take many hours and potentially
many days before they overheat.
So if those fuels,
those fuels should be tested in our art.
We were innovation central here in
California,
so we should be testing these,
these innovative meltdown proof fuels,
um,
and then really pioneering their use and
their diffusion throughout the whole,
um,
around the whole country and around the
whole world.
So I think,
um,
and then,
you know,
there's just so many other needs for
that energy.
Basically,
if you have abundant,
cheap,
clean energy,
then you can desalinate water.
This whole water crisis that Los Angeles
and California find themselves
periodically in doesn't need to exist at
all with cheap,
abundant and clean energy.
You can recycle the water,
you can disseminate the water.
There should be plenty of water for the
farmers and for people that live in the
cities.
La should be green as idea that we have
to turn off our water.
Is,
is just part of that forced deprivation
and,
and manufactured scarcity that came out
of an ideological turn,
you know,
against the prosperity in the seventies.
That's what I want to.
I think that's the revolution that we
want to offend your telling me.
Everywhere I go,
we're in between the roads go in one way
or the other and they have the grass
that's not green anymore because we're
saving what it is.
That's actually not necessary.
You don't need to do it.
I mean,
yeah,
it will cost some energy to desalinate
and to recycle.
But look,
we agreed to the whole desert in
California was deserts and turn them
into farms.
This,
you know,
this whole area was very arid.
Um,
we have the technology to produce
abundant water.
And abundant and greenery and,
and we,
that's in abundant greenery is wonderful
for a lot of reasons that keeps the
city's cooler.
It captures carbon and um,
you know,
so there's just,
and it makes life more pleasant.
But this idea where we all have to sort
of this austerity,
this forest sacrifice,
austerity really starts with an attack
on cheap,
clean energy and,
and in particular on nuclear.
Anything I needed to know a lot of the
social stuff with you.
I have a of,
I could probably figure
it out.
Yeah.
Just buy everything else.
I know.
I don't think the government should
decide who gets married.
We're good to go.
I mostly think that stuff has been a way
to just drive us apart.
And I mean,
Trent is.
Trent does anything.
Transgender bathrooms.
It was like one of the big issues facing
California.
Nobody does,
you know,
um,
I don't even think that people in North
Carolina or wherever that now you think
it's a big issue there.
I know.
So I think like,
you know,
I,
I'd like to actually get to a place
where it's like we're talking about
what's the common good and not,
you know,
what effects this interest group or
this,
you know,
I,
I just,
I think that identity politics has just
gone really too far.
It's made us lose sense of who we are as
a people.
Yeah.
Well I feel like that might be the
sentence we should end this on because I
had been looking,
my whole audience says I've been looking
for somebody that sounded like a
sensible,
a Democrat that I could,
you know,
try to want to support.
Oh,
you know,
real quick,
uh,
my former guys,
Zoltan Istvan is also running for
California here as,
is he running well he's a transhumanist,
technically a party that can run or is
he running as an independent do?
Well,
you can.
Um,
what's cool is that we have,
will told an open primary and so anybody
can go for anybody.
And so if you're Democrat you can go for
a Republican and independent just means
declined to state.
So yeah.
So,
um,
but maybe you're gonna endorse me,
not talk about that after,
but I had been looking for a Democrat
that I go,
oh,
that's what demo.
Yeah,
it is.
And yet you're not ignoring the future
and we'll know because in some ways you
go like it was the Democrats pre 1975
that believed in the future.
The ones after that side kick away the
ladder.
What's unforced scarcity and let nobody
else come and enjoy this beautiful
paradise that we have.
But there's plenty of room,
you know,
this is a,
this is a state I want to get back in
touch with the values of abundance and
opportunity and an openness that I think
had been shot and not.
And not just by the left either,
I think by both sides.
Yeah.
Well listen,
it's been a pleasure talking to you.
Good luck on the campaign.
And for more on Mike and his campaign,
you can go to Shelan Burger.org.